[Music]
mr lowe this is laura from texas
not only are you attractive on the
outside your love for your sons
and wife make you even more attractive
for sure
have you ever interviewed your wife or
sons on your podcast
i looked back and didn't see that but
wanted to know if that was something
that you would be interested in doing
we'd love to hear more about them and
love to hear
their side on what you're like as a
father
and husband love your podcast
keep it going bye hey laura well first
of all
thank you that's really really sweet and
makes me feel great that is a great idea
to interview my boys and cheryl
that's a great idea by the way we're
coming
you can see us on family feud coming up
it was cheryl's um cheryl's obsessed
with family feud
and she's impossible to surprise
impossible
and i managed to get her to the set
family feud without knowing where she
was going
only for her to discover that she was
playing in it
and it airs on june 6th
so um if you really want to see the lows
in action
that that would be a good taste um
but in the meantime uh i i actually am
gonna
i you should be the producer of this
podcast because no one else
my highly paid team has ever come up
with that idea
you'd think but no you did
and i am gonna do that and i will do
that and you're absolutely right
i do adore those three lunatics my sons
and my
my wife and um i've always felt if i
could stomach it
if i could stomach doing a reality show
of my family
it would make the kardashians look like
romper room
um so maybe some of that will come out
when we uh when we do this interview
thanks for listening